so in the last few videos we've been
focusing on how the atmosphere changes
as you get higher and higher up and in
the last video we talked about some
radiation concepts and if you missed
that episode then check that out over
here and using those concepts we're now
going to look at things a little
differently we're going to examine how
the atmosphere changes in latitude and
in time and focus on a particular
feature near the pole in the
stratosphere called the stratospheric
polar vortex in talking about the polar
vortex we first need to talk about what
makes the poles special and in
particular why they're so cold now in
the last video we talked about radiation
energy that's emitted as an
electromagnetic wave with its properties
dependent on its wavelength and to start
this video off I'd like to extend those
radiation concepts a little further and
talk about something called radiation
balance this is the idea that the
earth's temperature is determined by it
being in thermodynamic equilibrium with
the Sun now equilibrium it means that
the same mass energy is emitted by the
earth and absorbed by the earth and the
thermodynamic part the first the fact
that the energy emitted by both the Sun
and the earth is thermal radiation so it
depends on the temperature of the Sun
and the earth so the earth's temperature
if it's in thermodynamic equilibrium is
the temperature at which the it gives
out as much energy emits as much thermal
energy as it absorbs from the sun
bearing this in mind then can we explain
why the poles are so cold now you might
argue that because the same amount of
energy is arriving from the Sun at the
poles as is at the equator that the two
should be at the same temperature
because they're in thermodynamic
equilibrium right same eye of energy in
equaling the same amount of energy out
means that they should be in thermal
equilibrium at the same temperature but
making that argument ignores a really
important part of the system and that's
geometry consider a vertical plane
that's being illuminated by a big light
source now this light source is giving
out a certain amount of energy per
square meter let's say a hundred watts
per square meter and because our plane
is parallel to it it's receiving an
uniform amount of energy across it a
hundred watts per square meter
now if the earth was a cube like a
Minecraft world then the side facing the
Sun at any given time would be receiving
the same life
radiation at every point and so would be
at the same temperature but the earth
isn't a cube it's a sphere and so it's
surface is curved that means that if the
earth's equator is parallel to our light
source the Sun then areas towards the
poles are tilted with respect to it and
we can examine what that means by going
back to our plane and tilting it with
respect to our light source doing so we
can see that the plane now receives less
energy in total because it occupies a
smaller area from the perspective of the
light source an absorbing less energy in
total means that less energy is being
absorbed per square meter and that means
that the plane will equilibrate at a
lower temperature because less energy is
coming in that means that less energy
needs to be emitted thermally for the
plane to be an equilibrium and it can do
that at a lower temperature the greater
the angle between the light source and
the plane the less energy is incident on
the plane and so the lower the
temperature the plane will thermally
equilibrate at and because the poles are
very high angles to the Sun nearly 90
degrees they receive very little energy
and so they're very cold in fact the
poles will be even colder if it weren't
for the atmosphere to see how much of an
impact it has we can look at the moon
which receives about the same energy per
square meter
as we do but has basically no atmosphere
at all and on the moon we see about a
300 degree Celsius difference between
the temperatures are the pole and the
equator at midday now compare that to
the 70 to 80 degrees difference that we
see here on earth this is because the
atmosphere absorbs some heat and
redistributes over the surface of the
earth and so reduces the temperature
difference between the equator and the
poles as well as reducing the
temperature difference between night and
day the atmosphere is pretty useful the
next component in talking about the
stratospheric polar vortex what is a
vortex a vortex can be defined as a
region in a fluid where the flow is
primarily around an axis line or as I
tend to think of it a spinny thing a
vortex is how a physicist or a fluid
analysis would describe chunk of
spinning or road
in fluid or air while a meteorologist
would look at the same phenomenon and
describe it as a cyclone or an
anticyclone depending on which way
around the rotation is if the air is
spinning in the same direction as the
Earth's rotation then it's a cyclone or
is if the air is spinning in the
opposite direction to the Earth's
rotation then it's an anticyclone that
then means that if you're in the
northern hemisphere looking for the top
down
a cyclone rotates anti-clockwise while
an anticyclone rotates clockwise
slightly confusing but in the southern
hemisphere
it's the other way around yay for the
southern hemisphere the most common way
that cyclones form is due to a pressure
gradient an area of low pressure on the
Earth's surface the air is drawn into
and due to the Earth's rotation starts
to spin around now that's a topic that
we could cover in a lot more detail a
future course on meteorology but for now
all you need to know is that cyclones
are associated with areas of low
pressure now going back to the second
video again we talked about the ideal
gas equation which showed us the
relationship between the pressure
temperature and density of air and using
this in combination with what we just
talked about the fact that the Earth's
poles are very cold and making the
assumption that the density of air
across the surface of the earth is about
the same everywhere we can see that by
the poles being very cold the air here
is at a lower pressure than elsewhere
and that means a big old pressure
gradient which means a big old cyclone
otherwise known as a vortex a polar
vortex but to explain the stratospheric
polar vortex this isn't enough there's
another piece of physics involved the
mathematics of the thermal wind goes a
fair way beyond the scope of this course
but I wanted to include it just to be a
little bit more complete and the gist of
it is this if you have a horizontal
temperature gradient so two locations at
the same height having different
temperatures then winds which are
perpendicular to that temperature
gradient become stronger and stronger
the higher and higher up you go in the
atmosphere I'm probably gonna need to
explain that a little bit more what this
means is that by the equator being
warmer than the poles winds which blow
perpendicular for that temperature
gradient so from west to east if they
were blowing from north to south and
they be parallel to that temperature
gradient become stronger and stronger
the higher you look in the app
so in the stratosphere for example winds
get intensified by that temperature
gradient more than winds in the
troposphere below it do
so really thermal wind is a bit of a
misnomer what we're really talking about
here is a wind shear and the most famous
example of it is the jet streams which
in the mid-latitudes and exist roughly
between the stratosphere and the
troposphere and are these narrow bands
of really intense winds but what we're
talking about is even higher up in the
atmosphere because the other famous
example of the thermal wind is the
intensification of the stratospheric
polar vortex so let's finally look at it
a combination of the low pressures over
the pole and the temperature gradient
between the equator and the pole form
the largest feature in the stratosphere
the stratospheric polar vortex it's
about a thousand kilometres from one
site to the other and it extends from
the upper troposphere right the way
through the stratosphere so it's over 40
kilometres tool this thing is huge but
it doesn't exist year-round it's driven
by the temperature difference between
the equator and the pole and that
temperature difference decreases in the
summer months because the Earth's poles
tilts towards the Sun and so receive
more sunlight and so warm and so the
northern hemisphere vortex tends to
break up in about April having formed in
about November though there's a favorite
of leeway either side and the southern
hemisphere has its own vortex and for
various complicated reasons it tends to
be stronger than the Northern Hemisphere
version and it tends to last for longer
but the northern hemisphere version is
of more interest to us partly because
more people live in northern hemisphere
but also because it varies a lot more
the polar vortex at its peak is
characterized by very strong west to
east winds or westerlies and when I say
very strong I mean up to 200 miles per
hour in the stratosphere and 80 miles an
hour in the troposphere the polar vortex
doesn't mess around
and while all of this is fine and dandy
we still have an answer one very
important question we already talked
about the fact that the polar vortex
extends from the upper troposphere right
the way through the stratosphere all of
those being places where no humans live
so why do we care about the polar vortex
well the vortex acts to constrain air
over the poles and when the vortex is at
its strongest air from the polar region
struggles to break outs down to lower
latitudes due to conservation of angular
momentum and during the polar vortexes
strongest months and deep dark winter
months the pole is at its coldest and so
the trapped air over the pole can get
incredibly cold now what we haven't
talked about is how the strength of the
vortex varies over time because various
factors ranging from relatively simple
ones like the temperature difference
between the equator and the pole to
relatively complex ones like variations
in ep flux divergence due to changes in
planetary wave refraction ya mean the
the strength of the vortex varies over
time and variations in the vortex
strength means variations in how well
the ultra cold arctic air is kept
constrained to higher latitudes should
the polar vortex become very weak or
even be displaced from the pole then
that freezing air would spill further
south and bring freezing temperatures
and ice and snow and chaos with it so
it's just as well that doesn't happen
now I'm just kidding it happens a lot
and we're going to talk about those
events in the next video so in this
video we've talked about radiation
balance and thermodynamic equilibrium
and how it explains why the Earth's
poles are colder than the equator
because they receive less so in a
radiation due to the geometry of a
curved planet we've talked about what a
vortex is it being a spinny thing we've
talked about how the stratospheric polar
vortex is intensified by the thermal
wind and we've started to consider just
why the polar vortex might be important
next time we'll continue this discussion
and talk about the events called a
sudden stratospheric warming as the most
violent events in the stratosphere which
can have a significant impact on our
weather here at the surface as well as
being what I study for my PhD
thank you for watching if you enjoyed
this video and you'd like to support it
then you can do so on my Connors page
and if you did enjoy it then please
consider liking it and subscribe to this
channel for more educational content the
important thing is that if the a/o index
is negative and the polar vortex is
weaker than normal and so there's a
greater chance of some of that ultracold
air escaping down to lower latitudes if
that water hell hydrate
that's Jeff palaces textbook that's a
series of papers that I'm reading the
moment that's an award that I got for
the top